[Music]
you can hike through history and take
the family on a date with dates in this
week's vegas drives las vegas now's
rocky theis adventures to tacopa
california to explore the china ranch
date farm and bakery
[Music]
so we are amongst the original trees
right of the china ranch date farm tell
us the history behind the trees uh well
rocky uh these trees were planted about
a hundred years ago from seed
from a mail order catalog actually
and the people living here at the time
just threw them out by hand there was no
real spacing they just scattered and
grew like this and that's why they grew
kind of abstract like this they did yes
and they nobody tended to them for about
50 years so they
found water on their own and because
this is considered an oasis we are a
real
deal desert oasis we're looking up at
the dates right now how many are you
producing roughly i would say 40 000
pounds of a year we're processing we
have about 15 different varieties here
some of them are
hybrids that only grow here okay and
then other ones we brought in from
other areas like iraq
morocco
and north africa so you know most states
are native to the middle east so we
harvest dates in the fall and winter
months so it's about half the year we're
harvesting
and then in the springtime we're
pollinating and then the summer is when
everything ripens they need about
90 days of 100 degree temperature or
higher so you're a great place so we
just took our uh date date to the next
level okay we are in the lift kayla
tell us what your job here
is on the farm so i am actually the
field manager i have everything to do
with the dates from pollinating to tying
down and bagging them all the way up
until harvest currently we are in the
tying down phase which means that we
take one of the bundles and we actually
tie it to one of these branches with a
piece of twine that way it doesn't break
under its own weight there's actually
five different stages to a date right
now we're in the calal phase which is
the third phase so
right now they will start to turn yellow
you can kind of see one here it's
starting to get a little bit of color on
it that is actually the sugars and the
dates starting to produce
and then that will start to become more
of a sweet little fruit it'll soften
next and become chewy and that's when
you get the last final stage being the
tamer
i like the tamir stage yeah it's my
favorite american
what is your favorite way to eat a date
plain and cold that's the way to go or
in a smoothie smoothies are really
really good to eat a date i have one
every single day speaking of date
smoothies i think that's where we're
headed now yes i just had this morning
[Music]
with the smoothie we start with some ice
and a frozen banana
do two scoops of
this date paste here
and then let's see we'll do some cashews
this is a mesquite flour dairy free
[Music]
there's a nice smoothie right there
[Music]
wow
oh my gosh this is so good
it's not too sweet it's just perfect
yeah i think it's good
i think it's great i think don't be
modest this is great